Please welcome Nicola Coughlan.
Nicola!
(audience applauding)
Okay, look at you.
Oh my God!
You look so Traci.
Hug, hug, hug, hug.
Oh my gosh!
(audience applauding)
Oh my gosh.
Hi!
Have you seen any of our obsession with yourselves?
I absolutely have.
I was right on top of all of it.
I was honored and delighted.
It was amazing.
It was just so surreal
because it all happened in December, 2020
when we were all locked in our houses.
And I was like, "How have they seen the show?"
"How do they know who we are?"
It was mind blowing.
Everybody watches the show.
I mean, it changed lives.
Now, I don't wanna be a spoiler.
So, if you don't want any spoiler alerts, cover your ears.
One, two, three.
Your character has been revealed-
Yes.
As none other than the one.
Lady Whistledown!
It's you?
It is.
Yes, I know.
Okay.
I was screaming at the TV.
Of course, this is like the gossip columnist of the town.
All season one, we're trying to figure out who it is.
It's you!
I know, it was crazy because they were not sure
whether they were gonna reveal it or not.
It was sort of a debate
but then what you see in season two,
you can see why they revealed at the end of season one.
That's a tease.
Okay.
And you know,
you are pulling the puppet strings to so much of the show.
Yeah.
And not until the last second 82 million people were like,
I know.
How did you keep the mystery knowing...
I did not keep it well, unsaid in any way, shape or form.
Really?
I was like,
I would go to people like during lunch break,
"Do you know who Lady Whistledown in is?"
They were like, "No", I was like, "It's me, it is me"
So, that's how I sort of tempered it
without telling the rest of the world.
I was very good at just telling people on set
that it was me.
And it was crazy
because it was such a huge secret to keep
even doing press for season one,
they're "Lady Whistledown", I was like...
What about your friends?
We're like, "Look me in the eye, is it you?"
I did tell a lot of them and they were so mad at me.
So this season I've been not allowed to tell them anything.
They don't wanna know anything about it.
I watched a little bit with my mom already.
And they were turning around at me, going...
And I was like, "I know, didn't I do good secret keeping?"
"Am I not better at that than thought I was?"
And it's not like easy becoming Penelope.
At sometimes there's real transformations-
Oh yes.
Especially in period.
Oh yeah.
And look at this time lapse video.
Yeah.
I just love this.
In my Hamilton sweatshirt with a puppy on my knee.
Aww!
So every day you're going through...
And this takes hours, right?
This takes about three hours.
I can say, yeah.
So, it's like a big transformation
and that wig is made, you know, hair by hair,
like it's all really intricate,
all the colors, like they're matched up.
There's so much thought that goes in.
Didn't you have a teacher tell you
that you would never
Do a period piece?
Yes, yes, yes, yes.
They also told me I didn't look Irish
which I don't know what that means.
Because you're Irish.
They were like, "You do not look Irish."
I was like, "Okay, I will do I wear a wooly jumper"
"and carry some shamrocks and then..."
I dunno.
Yeah, they said to me, you'll never do period.
And I was like, "Okay."
And at drama school you're like a little sponge.
You'll take everything a teacher says.
You'd be like, "Sure, sure, sure."
So I would tell people like,
"Well, I'll never do period drama."
They said, yeah, "My face was too modern."
Live your life.
Absolutely.
I'd like to tell him he was wrong
82 million times over.
Thank you, Drew, thank you so much.
(audience applauding)
Now, were the casting directors and everybody like excited
about "Derry Girls"?
Because everybody loves Derry Girls.
And was that something-
Yeah.
That they were excited by?
Look, there you are.
Did they mention it?
I'm always very fashionable in every role.
With Penelope, it's the yellow dresses,
With Claire, it's a lot of headbands,
a lot of 90's regalia.
Yeah, we just finished the final season of it, filming it.
I know it's wild.
It's just a really, really special show.
It's about teenage girls growing up in Northern Ireland
during the troubles.
And yeah, it's just beautiful and heartfelt,
but it had, you know, an endpoint
and I think there's something really special about a show
that knows when the time is to exit the stage.
Yeah.
(upbeat music)